and you're naked a lot how does that
feel you have no choice right no it's
like every scene is like
he sleeps with this person he does this
with this person naked i think on
euphoria it comes with the territory of
the character jacob lrd is getting real
about his sex scenes on euphoria i
learned a lot about myself while
appearing on the ellen degeneres show
the 24 year old actor opens up about
what it's like getting nude in front of
his cast and crew for the hit hbo drama
the crew has been the same
from the first season through the second
season so it's kind of it's like getting
naked in front of your family yeah
which also is weird which is weird it's
always just to let you know
jacob who plays nate jacobs on the show
has filmed many steamy scenes with
co-stars sydney sweeney and alexa demi
who play his classmates cassie and
maddie
you can control what i wear
and in turn
he made maddie feel better
and after two seasons of all that sexy
goodness jacob says he's pretty used to
it i think on euphoria it comes with the
territory of the character so i'm kind
of you know he's just
ultra masculine macho jock so those guys
i think tend to get around pretty
shirtless so it's it's sort of okay and
we have an intimacy coordinator her
name's mam and she's like she's a second
mother she's like you are you
comfortable are you okay to the point
where you're like yeah we're fine but
it's not the first time we've seen jacob
ditch his clothes on camera remember
this scene from kissing booth 2 with
joey king
[Music]
the australian actor couldn't help but
blush when ellen helped him understand
why he's landing these roles i've done
some movies where it gets to the point
where it's like
he goes to the mall shirtless and you're
like why
why would you possibly like well because
look at you that's why
and when nate isn't busy getting down on
euphoria he's getting revenge
nate don't do this i i'm begging you
don't do this you are
who you are
i don't think you're ever gonna change
major spoiler alert ahead if you haven't
seen the season two finale in three
two one
nate turns his dad cal into the cops i
wanna talk about that confrontation
between nate and cal what was that like
for you to act opposite jacob in those
scenes i love acting on opposite jacob
that's my dude yeah he and i have a
pretty good connection um
he's very present you know jacob's a
really solid actor he's a he's a dynamic
actor as well um
but uh
we
we have a solid connection and that
scene just kind of played out it seemed
pretty effortless at the time
um and it felt natural it felt like this
was kind of the sort of the natural
evolution of how this sort of
relationship between father and son
would go
and although their father-son
relationship isn't great on the show
off-screen eric and jacob couldn't be
tighter
you know i work a lot with jacob so we
just kind of kick it and talk craft and
books that we've read
and you know if you leave your phone out
he will steal it and take selfies
yeah i wish i had my phone on me i'd
show you some of the selfies you took
so you got a collection now i've got a
collection of jacob allordy's selfies in
my phone now it's unclear if fans will
see more of cal in season three as he
faces prison time but jacob and eric
told et there could be more story to
tell given the change in the in the
second season i imagine it would just be
a complete shock again it would just be
like it could be a completely new show
again you know uh eric don't you feel
like you guys have six seasons in a
movie in you
oh my god six seasons
i know of this material sounds like a
lot
maybe maybe four in a movie
maybe four in a movie
[Music]
you